hi my name is jacqueline this is my msx  story so before coming we had lots of  expectations about this year we expected  for jk to pursue his academic career and  for me to focus time on the family but  beyond that i found this whole new space  in developing my personal  skill sets and open up new opportunities  in a career which i never imagined i  would pursue and i pursued lots of  classes in particular i took an advanced  design thinking class where i got to  help lead a team from the city of san  jose work through an actual business  problem using design thinking skills to  actually  uncover disruptive solutions for a  problem that they had this gave me the  confidence to then pursue a new career  in design thinking when i go back to  singapore  [Music]